I have an equation right here it's a
second degree equation it's a quadratic
and I know it's graph is going to be a
parabola this was a review that means it
looks something like this or it looks
something like that because the
coefficient on the x squared term here
is positive and it's going to be an
upward-opening parabola and I am curious
about the vertex of this parabola and if
I have an upward-opening parabola the
vertex is going to be the minimum point
if I had two downward-opening parabola
then the vertex would be the maximum
point so I'm really trying to find I'm
really trying to find the x value if you
could imagine the X I don't know where
actually where this does intersect the x
axis or if it does at all but I want to
find the x value where this function
takes on a minimum value now there's
many ways to find a vertex probably the
easiest there's a formula for it and we
talk about where that comes from in
multiple videos where the vertex of a
parabola or the x coordinate of the
vertex of the parabola so the
x-coordinate of the vertex is just equal
to negative B over 2a and that just the
negative B you're just talking about the
coefficient or B is the coefficient on
the first degree term is on the
coefficient on the X term and a is the
coefficient on the x squared term so
this is going to be equal to B is
negative 20 so it's negative negative 20
over 2 times a over 2 times 5 over 2
times 5 well this is going to be equal
to positive 20 over 10 which is equal to
2 and so to find the y-value of the
vertex we just substitute back into the
equation the Y value is going to be 5
times 2 squared minus 20 times 2 plus 15
which is equal to let's see this is 5
times 4 which is 20 minus 40 which is
negative 20 plus 15 is negative 5 so
just like that we're able to figure out
the coordinate this coordinate right
over here is the point 2 comma negative
5 now it's not so
satisfying just a plug and chug a
formula like this and we'll see where
this comes from when you look at the
quadratic formula this is kind of the
first term it's that it's the x-value
that's halfway in between the roots so
that's one way to think about it but
another way to do it and this is
probably will be a more lasting help for
you in your life because you might
forget this formula and so really just
try to Rima nip you late this equation
so you can spot its minimum point and
we're going to do that by completing the
square so let me rewrite that so we have
y is equal to and I'll write it as and
what I'll do is out of these first two
terms I'll factor out a 5 because I'm
going to complete a square here and I'm
going to leave this 15 out to the right
because I'm gonna have to manipulate
that as well
so all right that is 5 times x squared
minus 4x and then I have this 15 out
here 15 out here and I want to write
this as a perfect square and we just
have to remind ourselves that if I have
X plus a squared that's going to be x
squared plus 2ax plus a squared so if I
want to turn something that looks like
this if I want to turn something like
this to a X into a perfect square I just
have to take half of this coefficient
and square it and add it right over here
in order to make it look like that so
I'm going to do that right over here so
if I take 1/2 of negative 4 that's
negative 2 if I square it that is going
to be positive 4 I have to be very
careful here I can't just willy-nilly
add a positive 4 here I have an equality
here if they were equal before adding
the 4 they're not going to be equal
after adding the 4 so I have to do
proper accounting here I either have to
add 4 to both sides or actually be
careful I have to add the same amount to
both sides or subtract the same amount
again now the reason why I was careful
there is I didn't just add 4 to the
right-hand side of the equation remember
the 4 is getting multiplied by 5 I have
added 20 to the right-hand side of the
equation so if I want to make this
balanced out if I want the Equality to
still be true I either have to now add
20 to Y or have to subtract 20 from the
right-hand side so I'll do that I'll
subtract 20 from the right-hand side so
I added
five times four if you were to
distribute this you'll see that I could
have literally up here said hey I'm
adding 20 I'm adding 20 and I'm
subtracting 20 this is the exact same
thing that I did over here if you
distribute the 5 it becomes 5x squared
minus 20x plus 20 plus 15 minus 20
exactly what's up here the whole point
of this is that now I can write this in
an interesting way I could write this as
y is equal to 5 times X minus 2 squared
and then 15 minus 20 is minus 5 so the
whole point of this is now to be able to
inspect this when does this equation hit
a minimum value well we know that this
we know that this term right over here
is always going to be non-negative it's
always going to be non-negative or we
could say it's always going to be
greater than or equal to zero so it's
going this whole thing is going to hit a
minimum value when this term is equal to
zero or when x equals two when x equals
two we're going to hit a minimum value
and when x equals two what happens well
this whole term is zero and Y is equal
to negative five the vertex is to
negative 5